hello everyone and welcome to a game
that has been suggested many many times
by many different people on many
different platforms but uh it uh it
hasn't been until now that i've decided
to actually show we constantly have
something else that is happening in the
chess world especially now with so many
things just happening there are
tournaments overlapping and it's very
hard to
find a moment where where something is
not happening so today i decided to
finally show it as it's uh the game that
uh
seems to have given magnus this uh term
or rather to give his play the term the
magnus effect and now this is uh very
much different from the magnus effect in
physics
although someone who named the the well
his style of play the magnus effect
might have had this uh idea in mind so
for those of you who are interested in
physics uh the magnus effect is the
generation of a sidewise force
on a spinning cylindrical or spherical
solid immersed in a fluid liquid or gas
when there is a relative motion between
the spinning body and the fluid named
after the german physicist and chemist
h.g magnus and yeah i thought about it
that there could be a way to maybe
describe carlson's play using this but
it it would not be easy if any of you
guys have any uh such uh
well uh correlation in mind do share in
the comment section uh so we can all
enjoy it uh but that being said let's
check out the game and see what the
magnus effect is uh when it comes to
chess
uh and it's uh
really really a wonderful wonderful game
he's playing against uh
dutch grandmaster cp ernst and
as you'll see after the game they both
did incredibly well in this tournament
it was into in 2004 it was the chorus
tournament uh and nowadays it's called
the the vikings of course you guys know
what it is the tata steel
uh but back in those days you had the
chorus you had the a group the b group
and maybe even a smaller tournament uh
who knows at one point even my
grandfather played
in in vikings at some chorus level i
have no idea which one
but yeah let's check it out and enjoy
this beautiful masterpiece so magnus
with the white pieces opens with e4 uh
we have c6 by ernst uh d4 and d5 so
normal karaoke on defense here knight to
c3 d captures an e for knight captures
and bishop to f5 this is the classical
variation of the karo khan knight g3
attacking the bishop bishop the g6 and
of course h4 going after that bishop
with h5 so uh
ants that makes some room for the bishop
he plays h6 now you can retrieve the
bishop to h7 now comes knight to f3
knight to d7 and now h5 this is the
spasky variation and this uh
definitely stands the test of time like
i said the game was from 2004 uh that's
18 years ago and it's still
very very much playable uh in
2022 so bishop to h7 now comes bishop to
d3 offering a trade of light square
bishops bishop captures queen captures
and now a6 and here magnus develops the
bishop bishop to f4 saying that he is
most likely castling queen side bishop
to d2 or bishop to f4 are still to this
day the absolute top moves uh in in this
position so knight g2f6 uh and queen
side castles by magnus with bishop to e7
and now magnus goes for knight to e4
now interestingly uh here uh in uh in
this day and age that we live in king to
b1 is the move that is being played as
the engine slightly prefers it to the
move that was played in the game uh but
still the positions that uh you know
arise are pretty much the same so yeah
it's uh you know people play just
because the engine says so so knights to
e4 now comes queen to a5 putting
pressure on the a2 pawn and king to b1
so okay the prophylactic king to b1 is
played uh
nonetheless we have castles by uh ends
and now comes knight captures on f6 we
have knight captures on f6 and knight to
e5 now uh we have rook 8 to d8 and this
is where things get very very
interesting now of course black wants to
play c5 you will not be able to capture
anything as the queen is on d3 and the
magnus plays queen to e2 and this is uh
not just to get the queen away from the
d file but also it has a very very
particular threat in mind uh that black
misses uh as i it's it's not a very
obvious one so here black continues with
c5 it's a move you really want to play
in most of the lines of of of the carl
khan you want to get that
pawn away from c5 traded for white's a
very strong central pawn but here it
simply doesn't work and this gives
magnus an opportunity to go for a
beautiful beautiful attack that is
almost impossible to calculate so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find carlson's idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
well a seemingly impossible idea to spot
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is knight the g6
that's the good stuff and now the
problem is uh the rook is being attacked
as well as the bishop and the bishop is
undefended and it seems like you only
have two good choices here one is to
capture the knight
the other one is to move the rook and
defend your bishop on e7 and this indeed
is the only move for black but it's so
complicated uh that you guys will enjoy
it so much so let's say rook f2e8 is
played we're going to capture the bishop
here and after rook captures knight now
we just played d captures on c5 and now
you have a problem uh you can't really
capture back with the queen because the
rook on d8 would hang and if you do
nothing well we're just going to put a
bishop on d6 and that's a huge problem
for black so what might happen is you
you might think okay let's play rook
captures on d1 now comes rook captures
on d1 and queen captures on c5 but now
again bishop d6 and white just wins so
obviously we can't play that so the only
thing black could do is play knight to
d5 now okay you are attacking the bishop
on f4 but still we play bishop to d6
attack the rook and once the rook moves
now we can play c4 we challenge the
knight knight back to f6 and now we play
rook to h3 so it's completely crazy a
complete madness of a line
and black it doesn't really have all
that many useful moves at some point you
will want to challenge this structure
with b6 so you can capture here the
problem is uh if you play this and this
is indeed the strongest move we're going
to play rook a3 attack the queen once
the queen moves we're going to attack
the queen again and once the queen moves
and now we're going to play c captures
on b6 and offer the bishop here the
problem is you can't really capture this
you have to play a capture and b6 then
we capture with the rook and then our
bishop is nicely defended and the white
keeps all the edge uh if you play rook
characters on d6 then we just play rook
captures on d6 rook captures and b7
and of course we win the game there is
no stopping pawn to b8 so here
basically the best for black would be
captures captures and now you get to
play this position where that white is
just better and white or i mean white
has two two connected past pawns here uh
it's gonna be uh very very hard for
black to play this but this is the
absolute best that black had and once c5
is played that's pretty much it you're
never
you know getting past this this bishop
blockade uh so while uh terrible to play
it's the absolute best black uh has in
this position but um it's impossible to
calculate almost and it's very very ugly
to play so f captures and g6 was played
instead and now uh the attack begins
queen captures an e6 with check and of
course you can't play rook to f7 to
defend the bishop because we just
attacked the rook and that's it white
wins so instead we have king the h8 but
now not queen captures on e7 that would
allow black some breeding room and he
would be able to consolidate uh still h
captures and g6 and this h captures and
g6 is the only move that wins the game
for magnus but it's such a spectacular
move that uh i mean a very cold-blooded
idea saying that i now want to start
capturing on h6 with everything bring
the other rook to h1 and checkmate the
black king so how can you stop this well
knight the g8 is one way to try but
other ways aren't all that much better
now you add another defender to the h6
pawn also you're guarding the bishop on
e7 but magnus still starts sacrificing
bishop captures an h7 and now of course
you can't just wait for the for the
bishop to move just bishop d2 opens up a
discovery uh you can pick up the queen
but most likely will checkmate the black
king as well so g captures an h6 this is
the only move that doesn't result in a
forced checkmate rook captures an h6 now
again you have to capture if king g7
rook h7 is checkmate so uh we have to
capture here and the now comes finally
queen captures on e7 the only winning
move in the position but it's a very
natural one as we pick up the bishop and
threaten queen to h7 checkmate and is
there anything
else can do about this uh not really he
can put something in between the the
queen and the h7 square so he plays
knight to f7 uh but now comes g captures
on f7 uh just keeping an eye on this
square now queen to f6 followed by rook
to h1 and it's the game over so king g7
not allowing the rook to h1 move to come
with check but now rook to d3 magnus
even finds time for a nice rook lift
because the e1 square is covered by the
white queen so black cannot checkmate
magnus and
it's well it's important to notice that
magnus is down a full rook so if he
doesn't checkmate the black king then
he's just gonna lose because he's down
material so here black uses this idea
and plays a rook to d6 he knows that
magnus cannot move the queen away from
the e file because then queen to e1 will
be checkmate but magnus doesn't have to
do this rook the g3 with check we have
rooked the g6 as this is the idea behind
the black's rook lift now comes queen to
e5 check again this is the only winning
move and it's very hard to
uh
to go wrong here but or rather it's very
easy to go wrong here but magnus spots
the the correct idea now comes uh check
and you can go to the h file because
then of course we just have rook to h3
and that's game so here king captures on
f7 and now comes queen to f5 with check
and here uh black studied the position a
little bit and he realized that whatever
he does the game is uh just over because
uh with absolute best play magnus has a
forced checkmate in 15 moves but he just
played rook to f6 and allowed magnus
this spectacular checkmate with queen to
d7 the rook now guards all of these
squares and of course the queen prevents
the king from coming here the rooks
block the king from going up and down
and that's it black gets checkmated but
for your viewing pleasure i will show
what happens after the absolute best
defense uh king the e7 or king to e8
it's all the same because white's plan
uh
is is absolutely the same white's plan
is rook to e3 followed by queen captures
on f8 so here let's say king to e7 we're
going to play rook to e3 check now for
the king all the way to the queen side
king to d8 now we're going to capture
this with check now king has to move
again king to c7 queen to f7 check we
have king to c8 now comes queen to f5
with check we force the king to the
seventh rank and then we bring our rook
to the seventh so king c7 rook to e7
check king to b6 now we pick up the
other rook with tempo so queen captures
on g6 with check king to b5 this is
force the only move rook captures on b7
king to c4 or a4 doesn't really matter
queen to e6 with check and now after
king captures and e4 rook to d7 would be
checkmate as the queen covers the uh the
c4 square and there is nothing nowhere
for for black to go the pawn covers the
c3 square so black finally gets
checkmate but black saw all of this and
he said all right let's end the game
with a nice mating picture rook to f6 uh
queen to d7 checkmate yeah and uh well
uh the rest is history
now you might be thinking uh well okay
it's uh it's it's a brilliant attacking
game by magnus definitely worth of uh
well maybe even a great attacker like
tal himself
uh but how uh how well did black play
well black played a spectacular game uh
because here after uh this c5 move was
played which really gives magnus the
edge if he of course spots this knight
to g6 idea uh if you don't go for this
after knight g6 for this ugly rook after
e8 idea that we discussed everything
else is losing and even though he played
a very very strong moves uh there just
wasn't um
you know even a single resource to save
the game for black
uh and as i promised uh here are the
final standings of the tournament you
can see that uh uh september finished in
second place only half a point behind
magnus carlsen so
if this game for example ended in a draw
then he would be first and magnus would
be second which is very very important
you can see that he is an incredibly
strong player
but magnus won this game uh he only lost
one game and drove drew three games and
uh does he won the 2004 chorus
tournament
so yeah that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it really sorry it took me this
long to cover it uh so i really hope you
enjoyed it but it really uh i think this
is the first time that we've ever heard
the term magnus effect used for for
something regarding magnus usually it's
used for you know you can use it for
many things and mostly people just use
it for you know when magnus is playing
against maybe another 2800 player and
it's a completely drawn end game that
magnus somehow wins after 60 moves off
torturing the other guy
uh but yeah
i'm sure it can be used for other things
and here it was used to to describe this
uh well incredible incredible pressure
that magnus put on his opponent after
that slight imprecision we could say
uh so yeah once again i really hope you
guys enjoyed it i would like to wish a
very happy birthday to ricardo uh his
birthday was yesterday but i didn't make
a video yesterday so sorry about that
and i would like to thank the mushroom
of the nsa
usfd efri usfd efri and the big yak
axiclub for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day